hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on cannabis safety
trace analysis of pesticides
and mycotoxins via lc triple quadrupole
in cannabis flower and concentrates
by dr peter stone senior lcms
application scientist at agilent and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinth and i will be
moderating today's event before we begin
i want to encourage you to engage with
us you can submit as many questions as
you want at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that support tab found at the
top right hand corner or use that ask a
question box on the left
please welcome now our presenter dr
peter stone you may now begin your
presentation sir
so good day everybody um my name is
peter stone i'm a president of
technologies as a
applications
[Music]
development chemist
[Music]
today's talk uh is on the subject of
cannabis safety
which is a growing industry in
laboratories around the country as
each uh us state
legalizes for the recreational use of
cannabis
specifically today i'm going to be
talking about
pesticides and mycotoxins
uh analysis a trace analysis of those
lc triple quad in cannabis flower and
also how to actually analyze for those
in cannabis concentrates or
distillates as uh as as some forms of
those are actually called
so i will start off the presentation
actually with a disclaimer which we
at accident have to
have to express that agilent products
and solutions
are intended to be used for cannabis
quality control and safety testing in
laboratories where such use is permitted
under state
or country law
okay
with that said uh i'm gonna basically
just give you an overview of
the complete service basically uh that's
agilent can supply for the entire
cannabis testing laboratory and that
covers
virtually everything that uh state
legislative
legislature
and also country legislation such as
canada
require um
that would be anything from heavy metals
cadmium mercury etc
from ground
terpenes
[Music]
profiling
cannabinoid profiling or potency as we
refer to it
microbiology
screening
by a technique such as qpcr
and also we've got the pesticides and
microtoxins
which
are required in most states
across the country and also in canada
north america is what this presentation
is really focused on
uh together with all of those uh answers
or applications uh proven applications
we have can fund those downs actually
through
um other
aspects of what we can supply for the
whole
uh chain of events i guess for the lab
and that would be
a
software columns and supplies
and
[Music]
virtually any service going
in such as support
we've also created out of each of these
or most of these
techniques agilent e-methods which i'll
briefly
describe uh at the end of this
presentation so essentially what we're
focusing on today is a small element of
comprehensive cannabis workflows that we
and agilent have actually
developed
in the past two or three years
so
um
the workflows
comprehensive cannabis and i might
mention here that this is also
applicable to hemp analysis workflows
and if we look at the bottom of the
screens down to the left
we have
anything
from sample preparation
through to
columns and separation the actual
analytical equipment and methods
to perform such analyses
[Music]
we can also provide templates for
reporting your results see your lab
results and we've also got backup and
services in terms of maintenance and
support
so the key points of this presentation
are the residual pesticide and mycotoxin
quantitation is really challenging
especially in such a plant material as
cannabis or hemp plant
is
so
the the the ability to be able to
distinguish high concentrations
uh cannabinoids in terpenes away from
low concentration pesticides and
microtoxins
is very difficult
um and
there afterwards even with a clean up or
sample preparation
routine you need adequate separation
with chromatography to be able to
remove or
bypass co-extractives and other matrix
effects that might still be in the
actual sample ejected
other um
challenges uh that we face from
year to year for example is that other
new states or regions
come online they legalize
and absolutely significantly different
and fast evolving regulations from each
other for example
canadian regulations are extremely tight
and they have to actually require the
most pesticides
to out of north america to actually be
analyzed for
very challenging indeed
and also um as we as time marches on
many regulations are actually becoming
more and more restrictive and what i
mean by that is
the the the analog panels are increasing
and the
need to go to lower and lower action
levels i'll explain what that means in
the in the next slide
[Music]
is is is is a fluid
[Music]
part of reality at the moment as we
wrestle with uh how
and what that constitutes a safe product
so what we're going to really do in this
presentation is to describe a single
string sample preparation okay which is
applicable to both lcms and gcms
and it's basically
[Music]
one last step difference between those
today's presentation is for lcms only
but i will describe the split for gtms
gtms by the way is
in some respects for some analytes
superior to a single platform lcms
approach for
this type of analysis
so
what we're going to hopefully uh show
you today is
increased quantitative
robustness throughput
which the sample prep actually decreases
the need for some instrument maintenance
and cleaning etc
gcms is actually the best instrument to
quantify for many of pesticides however
different regions
do not necessarily require those
pesticides
and also
if you go with the two platform uh
you're actually prepared for the feature
just in case the uh analyst or sorry the
analyte panel actually increases
which has been the case of the trend
through
various states over the last few years
so this is just a venn diagram to show
you the variety
of different pesticide lists that can
occur
and do crop up in different regions and
different states
so you'll see that there's a crossover
with some and others in various
different states and and also you'll
notice the the uniqueness of a lot of
the pesticides in for example canada
on the right hand side there
so
so this slide is is actually to point
out uh an ever-evolving situation as
previously described
of recreational cannabis usage
legalizations to date in north america
you'll see that the green states here
are actually fully legalized for
recreational campus usage and
purple states also are however the
difference between the purple states and
the
others are blowing in green are that
they
have no mandated testing requirements
so the laboratories really that are
setting up across the country are in
these green regions and soon
um i'm slightly out of date by
uh just about
almost a week
some of these states some new states
have actually come online i understand
like montana
new jersey
and south dakota um
come online in terms of voting to
actually legalize cannabis usage in
recreational
forums
so
i mentioned the word action level
this is basically the quantitative
concentration a pesticide cannot exceed
and it defines the pass or fail results
of an analysis or batch
depends on what happens to the batch
there afterwards if they fail for
example in the relevant region or state
however in
california for example a fail would
constitute a batch of produce flour or
concentrates etc being
destroyed which is a lot of money
the lower limit of quantitation or llq
you see that through some of these
slides today that is basically it's not
necessarily the action level however it
is the imperatively determined
lowest concentration
from your instrument that is confidently
quantified
and finally lod or limit of detection
that is empirically determined as the
lowest concentration that is confidently
differentiated from noise from your
instrument
okay it's always lower than the yellow
key or llp
so just to
outline the
kind of panel i mean i've actually
pulled out 67 pesticides here plus five
micromicrotoxins and one synergist which
is colored in red mgk264
this is the california list
but i've pulled this out just to
demonstrate
for those of you that uh know anything
about these pesticides that we've got
full range of uh all sorts of analytes
from very polar to very non-polar
types so we're actually doing these
analyzing these in one
complete method is actually quite
difficult so however we have
uh
excluding obviously the the bold face
for analytes there
which are reliably
analyzed via gcms techniques
and i've actually
basically pulled those all together so
that you can actually see the wide range
there are 67 pesticides here five
microtoxins
the analysis is one thing i'm not going
to bore anybody today with
acquisition shopping lists you know
source parameters etc but what i'm
actually going to focus on is very most
important aspect of this analysis and
that is sample preparation it's the
important element to be successful with
with the
pesticide analysis trace analysis
excuse me
so the first slide here is is focused on
cannabis flower
um i'm showing it as a multi-platform
analysis it isn't necessarily the case
for some states or some regions
however what you're actually seeing here
is approximately
20 samples
a 45 minutes
[Music]
task
and that is basically in several steps
we've got
seven steps in total
and we're focusing on the top step for
the lcms system
at the end which is step seven
so um typically you would weigh say as a
representative sample a gram of chopped
cannabis flower into a vessel of some
kind
and shake that
um for at a high rate with
a device like a gene grinder something
like that
for about five minutes
then adds about 15 ml of sig nitro shake
or vortex for another five minutes at
high speed
and then what i do which is an optional
step is to centrifuge
that's
a solution for that mixture to actually
get the pellet
separated from the supinate
this supernatant from this step then is
decanted as a required into the sp
cartridge which is a sample q c 18 end
capped sp cartridge the number is there
important to note here actually that we
use gravity illusion so it does take
about 10 to 15 minutes in total to
actually lose through the cartridge
and basically once all of that solution
is is
into or the meniscus of that solution is
finally into the
packing material at the bottom we add a
further allocate of acetonitrol which is
a wash solution from the original vessel
into that cartridge and then a final
second five mils of seed nitro into that
cartridge and i lived fully
into a tube
we bring that
solution back up to 25 mils
and then we take 50 microliters of that
for the lcms system and mix it with 450
microliters of 25 percent
to 75 water methanol volume for volume
okay
and then that's ready to inject straight
into the mass spectrometer
now i did mention uh cannabis distillate
so concentrates earlier this is a
slightly different routine but it's
almost identical in in approach
so
first step here would be to weigh
half a gram of cannabis distillate
into a tube
okay
then vortex with about 30 ml of methanol
at high speed until all the distillate
has dissolved so that can take about
five to ten minutes
next we transfer all that sorry 15 ml of
that 30 ml solution
through the sp cartridge which is again
the same unconditioned sample q c18
encapped sp cartridge
via gravity illusion
we then add an allocated methanol 5 mils
and this is one change from the previous
routine we use methanol for lcms
into the tube wash out anything
that is left in the in the original tube
and add that through
the cartridge uh finally we then add
another five mils of methanol to fully
wash everything through and they'll
collect and then bring up the mark as we
did before it's 25 mils of methanol
that is essentially a hundred fold
dilution
and then we do the same thing to make a
250 fold dilution as we did in the
previous slide that i didn't mention
and by taking 100 microliters of extract
and mixing that with 150 microliters of
25
aqueous
to 75 methanol polling for body
into the vial and it's ready to shoot
that's works out about
100 injections per day
on this methodology
and equates to approximately 85
buildable samples if you discount things
like calibrations qcs etc
here is a slide showing
the typical recovery studies from both
the concentrates on the flower these are
averaged and as you can see
at a low concentration of the original
material 60 ppb
we're achieving very very close to 100
recovery from most of these one outlier
would be
phenoxamid which has slight
enhancement
and the second outlay would be the
pyrethrins which are pretty difficult to
uh
to
extract
anyway
but they still fall between
the legislation
that requires sample preparation
recoveries of between 70 and 130
such as california
also for the microtoxins
here are the recovery results such a
concentration of for ppp
and they're all very very close to the
100 recovery mark which again is
consistent with both state and regional
requirements
final step of the cost of the of the
example preparation uh that was a little
complicated why am i using 25 aqueous
and 75 percent methanol
is not a bit too high in terms of
organic to inject under all cms system
well yes it is
however
the solubility studies that we carried
out on these uh typical pesticide lists
show that the solubility
of about 14 of these outlined in green
is very poor with a concentration
aqueous concentration above 25 percent
and so
the sample prep routine does not go
above 25 in that final final step for
the lcms sample product
the instruments there afterwards if you
take a look at the uh
application note which i will show you
shortly in the next slide um
where the detail layer it actually
outlines what the auto sampler liquid
handling steps should be to actually
bring that
aqueous content up
in the finals stages of the uh
acquisition method
a couple of comments here on sample prep
for cannabis um we don't we tried
crutches
it didn't work it didn't work adequately
in recoveries for at least a handful of
these analytes um
they were the most polar analytes so we
had to move on and try something
different we tried also dispersive sp
it didn't have sufficient capacity it
also we also found that certain types of
dispersive
material co-scavenged
the acidic and the planar pesticides so
what we just presented there here is a
simple inexpensive sp
filtration cleanup
overview of the methodology of analysis
okay
i'm not going to go into the details
you will find those on the application
notes i'm just about to
show you however
what i'm going to say is that agilent
methodologies recommend
one of two front end or hplc systems
sample introduction systems and that
would be the 1260
or the 1290
binary pump systems
okay the second aspect is the detector
the mustang
we either recommend the altivo lcms
which is the compact instrument on the
left
or we
recommend the 6470 lcms triple quad
system which is
pictured on the right and i'll
go to the next slide
and reiterate that basically there's one
extra point i want to put
here is both the
1260 or the 12 1952 system must must be
fitted with a hundred microliter loop
and metering device because of the
sampling handling
uh routines that we've built into the
acquisition method to create a
the perfect chromatography for these um
the chromatography by the way is
actually based around the pore shell
packing material which is a porsche 120
phenol exile
and the column knife would be three
millimeters by 100 millimeters
um and we also recommend
the
guard column which is outlined there
the difference between the 1260
and the 1290 is not in chromatography
it's actually
due to differences in dead volume of
those pumping systems and essentially
that works out to
difference in cycle time for example
available sample of 11 minutes for the
1290 system and 13 minutes from the
12.60
the real details of everything in this
methodology is
outlined very specifically in each of
these uh application notes the top
application note the one pictured on the
left is actually
um
this it actually describes the
california michigan nevada oregon
washington
panels and typical results that you're
actually going to get from those
acquisition methodologies
the second
application out there which you just
have to take a note of the number and
search the agilent.com site
to get hold of those
uh it actually covers the requirements
and methodology that we recommend for
canadian target list
okay both of those are actually
just outlined in the
sample prep
for cannabis flower uh we've got the
concentrates application notes in
progress at the moment and we will
release those soon
what does the chromatography look like
this is an example uh this is california
uh state
uh list uh just an overlay at a constant
actual concentration 500 pp
which equates to um
[Music]
a pre-extraction concentration of 125
ppp
um
which is round about the
action level
of california state is slightly higher
in fact
of most of these pesticides
here's some example calibration curves
mostly everything is linear
in terms of its calibration
and these three analytes i picked
because first of all they're pretty
difficult analytes uh don't behave
themselves very often um
and also uh we have diminished um
even mectin diminished is
typically the first dilutive it's very
very polar um
ava mectin is one of the last
more nonpolar analytes which lives last
and spinoza
is actually towards the middle of the
chromatograph so
you're seeing typical results there
and if we thread into those further
you're actually looking at
examples of the chromatography that
you're going to see near the lloq the
lower limit of quantitation
this one
is a concentration of 100 ppt uh even
back in b1a i'll move on to the next
which is diminished
depending on what region you live in
um which is also 100 ppt
they're uh pretty significant signal to
noise
on both of those
and also the qualifier ions you see a4
and within
the limits that we set which typically
is 20
plus or minus 20
variation and here is the spinosan a
also at 100 ppt uh actual
um
[Music]
again looking very very good in terms of
signal tonight no smoothing
has been
done on any of these
here is the much lower concentration uh
at four dbp in cannabis matrix uh divide
that by 250 to get the actual
concentration um and
you're seeing that the
aflatoxins g1 g2 b1 b2 are actually
separating really nicely and
aquatoxin a which
can be a problem it's also there in
[Music]
quantifiable measure
so here's a table just showing um the
typical lo cubes with a 10 microliter
injection from
and these llqs actually represent the
original plant concentration before the
250 times or the
yeah the 250 times concentration
dilution
and looking through the list you can
actually see that for most of these for
all of these they're actually meeting or
more than meeting at least half
of the calibration action level here
which is one of the lowest in the u.s
states
okay and continued this is the rest of
the list again some outrageously low
measurements
in terms of ppp here from calibration
list
so i did mention e-methods what we at
agilent have actually done is to package
up electronically most of these
pesticide methods um that can be
purchased and downloaded directly from
the agilent website
or indeed coded with an instrument
purchase and
essentially what is included in those e
methods what is an e method
first of all you've got information
about the right instrument
configurations that need it to for the e
method to work properly
okay
very specific on that
second one is that you do
receive the optimized analytical methods
for sampling introduction chromatography
detection
and data analysis so that would be
methodologies for acquisition and data
analysis and reporting thereafter
thirdly
we also supply a list of selected sample
preparation protocols and consumables
best practices for sound implementation
and the all-important very very detailed
application that describes that method
specifically
another slightly busy slide here we've
got um
but the main
reason for putting this slide on is
actually to show you the variety of the
methods we have at the moment for
pesticides and microtoxin residue
analysis
the first
at the bottom there is
for
[Music]
california oregon
washington nevada michigan
and also it covers florida as well um
and that would be with a 1260 or an el
tivo combination we've got the second
one covers the same states
with 1260 6470 uh configuration and then
the third one covers canada only which
is specifically a 6470 1290 combination
for that
to work
as
stated
so this is my final slide it's just a
summary slide uh just to finish off this
brief presentation
so the e methods currently we have
available
cover california
canada florida
michigan nevada oregon washington
with their
specific pesticides like toxin panels um
these methods have actually proved their
worth over the last couple of years in
many current labs across the countries
canada and the us
and they're pretty established now
question that normally crops up do i
need both lcms and gcms for every region
or state
now some u.s states can require both
techniques to cover the whole of the
list that's uh specified for those
uh states
uh california nevada and florida are
three of those states that really
we do recommend gcms as well as those
for that
but
some of the states require lcmso you get
away with just the lcms system with pro
oregon washington michigan massachusetts
okay
newest states attending the forum follow
the oregon example
[Music]
and with
basically the same panels same action
limits etc sometimes more relaxed in
fact
and also the massachusetts panel is
currently being worked on and we have
three exclusive
need pesticides basically we have a
split of both 6470 detectors and ultibo
instruments
in all of the installed
laboratories across the country
currently so with that i'm just going to
wrap up and thank these people uh who
together with myself have actually
worked on toiled over and actually
developed
a lot of these methodologies for the
pesticide analysis trace analysis
and with that i'm going to applaud
for any questions you may have thank you
very much for listening
thank you dr stone for that incredible
presentation we now move to the live q a
portion of our webinar if you have any
questions this would be the time to go
for it and ask those questions we
already have some great questions coming
in
so let's take a look at the questions
so far
what new states are likely to legalize
for recreational cannabis usage
okay um
things have kind of changed in the last
week since the u.s elections and
[Music]
apart from those that i've already sort
of mentioned
in the presentation we've also got the
possibility now real possibility of
arizona montana
south dakota and new jersey um
who have all voted to legalize cannabis
in those states so
so
it's essentially opening up pretty uh
pretty much uh i'm going east
at the moment
thank you so much and how often do you
need to clean the ion source of the lcms
uh that's that's a good question um
essentially it depends on on your sample
throughput so if if you've got a low
sample throughput say
10 20 30 samples a day or a week even
or indeed if you've got up to 80 or 100
samples per day
going through the instrument then
that will determine how often we
recommend you cleaning the iron source
now
step the cleaning of the iron source is
actually very important
um
with the sample prep routine that we
actually have just described to you
for both the concentrate and the the
flour
essentially i would say
for a for a high throughput lab um
i would recommend cleaning the iron
source probably once a week
probably the monday
um
for lower throughput um then obviously
that could
stretch out a little bit however um
as a matter of course i would i would
just clean the iron source which takes
about five minutes um
once a week as as a matter of course
anyway uh
irrespective of your throughput
thank you so much now
dr stone what gcms instruments are
currently having these methods available
uh that's a good question um i i
definitely know
that the
um
let me put my slide up a sec actually i
know that the intuvo instrument uh
currently is included
on
that list but
let me just
be more specific and
take a look at my my list here
so we've got methods for the 8890 gc
with a 7010
triple quad gc triple quad
available for the us and canada list
there's 27 analytes inclusive in that
method
we've also got the methods for
intubo 7010 gc trip quad combination and
in all of these analyses
because it's trace analysis the the
triple quad is essential um you can't
get away with anything less
than tandem mass spec for this because
of the matrix
and we've also got a third method which
is a combination of
88 90 70 10 game
uh
gc triple card for canada only
local pesticide listing requirements
thank you so much now you had mentioned
to one audience member about cleaning
the ions ion ion source we have another
question regarding that um do you have
to clean past the ion source does it
need venting
that's a really good question as well
actually and something i should have
mentioned during the talk um
all of our instruments which i've
outlined the 6470b
and also the current instrument and also
the altivo
uh
triple quad
they both have
removable um
iron injectors or capillaries uh
whatever you want to call them
uh they can be basically taken out the
the the capillary the iron injector is
actually the
the main consumable on the front side of
the
iron optics bench itself that
normally takes a hit gets dirty
at the time
and
with high throughput anything between
three to six months it will need to be
taken out and cleaned um
lower throughput obviously uh a lot
longer than that
however the ability and the device which
we actually fit into both of those
instruments now is called the vac shield
okay and it allows you to actually take
the iron injector out the capillary out
in
a couple of minutes without venting the
instrument
and then clean it or indeed
swap a
cleaned or a new vocabulary in its place
and insert it back that takes me about
two minutes
um
if you're doing it for the first time uh
it'll actually take you probably ten ten
minutes
or something
and no put down requirement so
serviceability in that respect if you
want to go further into the instrument
and the most regular component or
consumable to actually be changing or
cleaning
it's now really simple to do
thank you so much and i think um
regarding the the back shields are also
available in some of the models from the
95c perhaps
uh i don't think so at this present time
um although
i may be wrong there um i love to check
yeah
yeah i i think john stossen who um is
part of the conference
um and everyone knows um i think he
mentioned that it is in fact um on the
95 c i'm getting a note to mention that
so the 95 c um
yes it does have a valve uh arrangement
which does six essentially the same
thing yes perfect
okay um regarding the instruments one
audience member asks does the 6490 work
as well that's the first part of the
question and if i remember correctly the
quad isolation windows are different in
the 6490 compared to the other agilent
um triple quadrupole uh which would
need more adjustment of the method
yeah of of course the the 6490 is
actually a uh a higher specification um
model
in terms of sensitivity uh it's it
actually incorporates it's the first
generation of inferno that we actually
introduced and of course the
the
operation of that requires extra
parameters extra tweaking and
and
um
little bit more care um in some respects
for that because there is a is a higher
specification instrument so
the the methods which are available at
the moment
really are for the lower specification
instruments because
that's all you need
john dr stone thank you so much for your
presentation today and for your
informative research would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
now i i just thank everybody for uh
attending uh hopefully it was
informative and you know
who to contact if you've got any further
questions so
please do
thank you very much
and as a reminder to our audience
questions we did not have time today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed via the email
you provided at the time of registration
and thank you again dr stone and to
everyone who participated we hope you
will check out the agilent exhibit hall
and enjoy the rest of today's event take
care stay healthy
bye for now